from Tigers battling gnomes tonight's
dueling Bishops there was a ton of
action in day one of the pro chess
League playoffs in the first match of
the day the Shanghai Tigers were hunting
for Norway gnomes and they were
successful the Tigers roared their way
to a landslide victory in match 2 the
Gotham Knights Drew their swords to
challenge the St Louis archbishops both
teams included big stars Hikaru Nakamura
on the knights and Fabiano caruana on
the Bishops in a wild reversal in round
three's Vladimir fetusia vs Fabiano
caruana the Bishops closed the knights
early lead Magnus Carlson himself tuned
into the broadcast right as Fabi and
Hikaru faced off posing the question has
there ever been more ELO between three
players on screen at one time with that
game ending in a draw the lead was too
much the knights marched to Victory